looking for a breakthrough on brexit
Boris Johnson is in Dublin making
last-minute appeals to his Irish
counterpart over the backstop the
insurance policy to avoid a hard border
between Ireland and Northern Ireland
after brexit for a man who last week had
Britain on course for a No Deal brexit
his message was more diplomatic I want
to get a deal like you I looked
carefully at No Deal I've assessed its
consequences both our country and yes of
course we could do it the UK could
certainly get through it but be in no
doubt that outcome would be a failure of
statecraft for which we would all be
responsible behind the smiles there is
tension irish prime minister liova
Radtke says there will be no concessions
on the Irish border issue and Ireland
would support an extension to the brexit
deadline the backstop continues to be a
critical component of the withdrawal
agreements unless and until alternatives
are found but we are open to
alternatives but they must be realistic
ones legally binding and workable and we
haven't received such proposals to date
meanwhile in Westminster Jeremy Corbyn
and other opposition leaders met to plan
their next steps on Monday a bill
designed to block a no brexit deal
becomes law MPs will then vote on
government plans to trigger an early
election that vote is expected to fail
Boris Johnson is then obliged to write
to the EU asking for an extension if he
can't present an acceptable deal to
Parliament by October 19th but the
government says he will not request that
extension the Prime Minister is still
promising to deliver exit by October
31st he says he has ideas but he has yet
to share them with Parliament or the
media we are heading towards a general
election probably not October but
November and he's working through that
prism and I think actually the way the
government are looking at it is if you
look at the focus groups how their
polling with the public when you get out
of Westminster a lot of
behind Boris and the way he's gonna
frame is his look I tried I tried to get
to my promise Parliament stopped me
therefore I was forced to go to an
election both sides are up against the
clock Parliament has just hours before
we shut down for five weeks while the
Prime Minister has just 40 days to come
up with a new brexit deal a deal that
Brussels has yet to see charlie Angela
al-jazeera London